lectures one on the incremental view
maintenance and the second on sampling
and the first one will be given by
Donald on incremental view maintenance
thank you good morning everyone
um
so uh we we heard over the past days uh
uh about lots of algorithmic problems
some of them uh uh basically solved
using Dynamic algorithms incremental
maintenance view maintenance is actually
a historical old term for for that type
of fully Dynamic algorithm but done on
queries in databases
so first I would like to acknowledge uh
my my my team Ahmed Hauser Johan and
milosh and also I'm grateful for
collaboration on this topic with Michael
exit relation AI particular Han Nico
Henrik and elsaadiq
um so what is the setting so as I
mentioned incremental view maintenance
uh maybe uh a misnomer because we don't
mean only to increment you know to add
to the database there can be also a
decremental aspect of it uh and an
alternative common naming that is in the
literature is fully Dynamic so that it
will support both inserts and Updates
this has been a well-established and is
a long-standing uh research problem
actually in databases
so our setting is this we look at the
both inserts and the and the deletes uh
we look at complexities for doing a
single Tuple updates to relational
databases and our interest is in queries
uh so maintaining the answers to queries
under such updates now towards the end
if I have the time I will also show you
something about maintaining uh let's say
machine learning models where uh you
know inspired by actually many talks
talking about semi rings and so on I
will show you a ring you know if I get
to that point right the ring for uh
maintaining covariance matrices over
joints in databases
and the kind of queries I'm going to
consider are not recursive so this looks
like a very limited scope however uh
there isn't much known nevertheless
besides you know a few uh uh you know
classical approaches called Delta
queries the de sombrero and I will
exemplify this there is a much else
known in terms of complexity in
particular optimality for these queries
and also uh how to uh whether there are
trade-offs involved in for instance
doing fast updates but then the answer
time may be actually slower or having uh
very slow updates but then the answer
time is fast yeah and whether we can
have a trade-off between these these two
aspects uh the objective is this
overview of recent and still to this day
very preliminary results yeah one worst
case optimal incremental view
maintenance the trade-offs I mentioned
and if I get to it uh IBM for complex
analytics so what is the incremental
view maintenance problem
you see it here uh we are given a query
and a database the query is considered
small and fixed the database is
typically very large and we are allowed
to have a pre-processing step to create
an auxiliary data structure and that uh
time it takes to do display processing
we call it pre-processing time in this
presentation and uh out of this data
structure afterwards we are allowed to
support access requests from users and
these are in the form of enumerate the
tuples in the answer of a query and uh
and uh to to capture this enumeration
time we use the notion of enumeration
delay which is the maximum of three
times is the time from the beginning to
enumerating the first record in the
database in some order uh then uh to
enumerate between uh one record and the
next yeah and until the very end to
enumerate a lot from the last Tuple to
the end of the enumeration right so
these are three times and that would be
for us the delay with which we do the
enumeration why are we interested in
delay there are several reasons one
reason is that this provides a more
fine-grained analysis of what's actually
going on for that particular query as
opposed to just say looking particularly
at the size because the size may be very
very large yet the query may be very
easy so just looking at the size is not
necessarily the right uh you know
measure of complexity for for some of
the queries now what I presented so far
could sit very well in the static I
would say query evaluation setting for
the dynamic one we get an additional
aspect namely that uh here from the very
bottom we get updates which may be to
both database but then we may have also
to carry them to the auxiliary data
structure and the time to maintain this
database and the data structure we
actually uh label as update time right
so we have then the pre-processing time
the enumeration delay and the update
time and we are interested in the
trade-off between these three uh
components of the complexity
uh good so the agenda is this first of
all uh uh being aware of the fact that
perhaps some of you are not database uh
you know uh you know experts I will
actually exemplify uh typical uh
incremental view maintenance techniques
by an example and for that I will use
the triangle count query that will allow
me to show you both existing upper
bounds new upper bounds and also a lower
bound then we look at uh let's say uh
the the kind of best we can hope for
namely can we get queries that have
constant update time and constant
enumeration delay and this turns out to
be the class of so-called Q hierarchical
queries and then we look at the
generalization from Q hierarchical
queries so what if we drop a property of
the queries this queue in front can we
then uh for instance uh still attain
some form of optimality is the question
and we will see that in detail and at
the very end if time allows I will
actually show you how we can maintain
models import in particular I look at
covariance Matrix and show you trees
which are built on pairwise Mutual
information in particular motivated by
by you know talks before this talk uh
where where we heard about such terms
so let me show you IVM techniques by
example so for that first let me
establish the data model
yes so uh how are is this framework
connect to the dynamic Halloween
framework that we saw uh yesterday so
can you is it is it just can you view
these queries as kind of a special
problem the things we're looking at
yesterday or so so typically what I
observed is that in in the algorithms
Community people focus on a specific
problem that can sometimes be phrases
specific query in databases however in
databases we try to reason about classes
of queries right so for instance
triangle count would be one problem
right in the algorithm so that's my my
very biased understanding but for us
it's one query in a larger class of
queries right another aspect which you
will see is that whereas my my
understanding from previous talks was
that there are completely different
algorithms and different techniques and
everything to deal with sparse and then
settings uh sometimes we have to account
for both such settings when Computing
the same query over the database because
the database may have Parts which are
both dense and sparse right so we have
to put them under the hood somehow
together okay so do results transfer in
uh I think yes I think they transfer and
uh I will also mention very briefly that
for instance the triangle count thing we
did uh was later on extended by by
people in the islands Community right to
for instance the batch processing in
parallel and all these other things so
there is actually uh uh you know I would
say uh communication both ways uh in the
other way for instance lower bounds we
we borrow from the algorithms Community
right like for instance these online
Matrix Vector multiplication conjecture
we've seen yesterday this is exactly
what I'm going to use more or less to
show lower bounds for for our queries
yes yeah so along that line yesterday we
were told that we basically can't do
anything better than Brute Force so
I
how can you do better so do you know
more information about data or so what's
the difference in the settings
you mean for a specific query or in
general uh so we saw there were many
Dynamic algorithms and in the uh at
least a result instead assuming some
yeah I suppose if we can do better so it
is true however that if we you know we
have an additional parameter here's the
the structure of the query
and sometimes the structure of the query
allows us to to lower the complexity of
the problem
so in many of these cases maintaining
the query result doesn't necessarily
mean you want to maintain a listing
representation of the answer of the
query you may uh represent you may
maintain instead a more compact
representation which comes with the
asymptotically lower complex right so
this is for instance one aspect that is
considered another one which I will
touch in the in the lecture is that you
can also use functional dependencies or
other types of constraints that hold in
the data so you see we can use on one
hand some properties of the data but
also we may use properties of the of the
query
uh in the
and and that and that you know makes it
a bit richer I would say right at least
from a database perspective
so uh okay so let me go back to the
model right there are no further
questions so
uh we consider relations like this right
with sets of uh tuples uh but um we
actually extend them a little bit so we
see them what is sometimes in AI is
called factors right we see them as
functions that map tuples two elements
from a ring
okay so here for instance I use the Z
ring and I use these numbers two three
and so on to represent the
multiplicities of the tuples and this is
actually very convenient for several
reasons one of the reasons is that it
allows me to treat uniformly both
inserts and deletes because inserts will
then be seen as pupils with a positive
multiplicities deletes us tuples with
negative multiplicities but you know
later on I will replace this ring with a
more complicated ring where instead of
this number I will have actually complex
objects that represent for instance a
partial covariance matrices which can
then be added subtracted and can we then
can maintain entire covariance matrices
so but you can think of it you can add
here whatever as long as it's a ring if
you don't want if you cannot make it a
ring then it can be a semi-ring in which
case you cannot you know just do inserts
right or you may have a very limited way
of doing deletes
yes
uh well we have two operators like like
like like in the same Arena right we
have the addition and multiplication
right but uh the difference to the same
ring is that the uh we have the additive
inverse
so you can have elements a and minus a
so that their sum makes zero which is
the neutral element
does the multiplication play around
in this ring yes yes it plays a role in
the same way it plays you know in three
relations in the sense that you have to
uh you know Trace somehow the the
computation over these multiplications
over this uh multiplicities to the to
the end result so I will show you an
example now so assume that these are
actually my tables adcca so this
represents actually the the column names
right in databases right and then uh
having a b here and there means that
basically I have a natural joint and if
you see natural join on the table RNs on
this column B please apologize Ahmed
he's extremely happy you know his
daughter was born yesterday
okay and he's very very happy about that
because we talked about that but I think
he forgot that I'm giving a talk now
um so which is completely excusable uh
and then you know between s and t we
have C right the column C and uh and
this means we also have a joint there
and we also have a joint between R and T
on a
okay so if we do the join R times s
times t
what does it mean it means that we look
at uh tuples that match up right so we
have the same B1 here and there the same
C1 here and there and A1 from here and
there right so we create a tuple a 1b1
C1 and what we do with the
multiplicities we just multiply them so
that's the effect of the multiplication
we have here
um and now we get the value of four but
there are several other possible
derivations several possible tuples in
the answer and in particular we can get
the other the other the other two here
right and then if you want for instance
to count the number of answers which
means you want to aggregate the way or
to you know use variable uh elimination
to get rid of a b and c then you will
get an answer which just maps The Empty
Tuple to the sum of these multiplicities
which is 19 here
yeah so this is like in databases
now
um I mean classical ones now imagine I
have this uh uh update and usually
updates I represent them with the delta
in front yeah and this says that I have
a new Tuple A2 B1 which is mapped to
minus two yeah so now I look up in the
database for relation R because it's a
Delta applied to R and I see that indeed
I have a to B1 and I have a value of
three so what is the effect the effect
is that
I have to erase this and now insert one
which uh which has a2b1 but now the
multiplicity is only one because I hate
to take three plus minus two and that
actually has an effect on the on the on
the result and namely you know combining
it with these blue guys here ending up
with this Tuple here that Tuple has to
be updated and uh as you can see we can
delete this one and now add instead a
new multiplicity three which then has
the effect of actually getting a overall
count of 13 not anymore 19.
now this example already shows something
uh uh uh you know quite a nice uh namely
that uh in in as the effect of One
update to the database you may not have
to recompute everything in the database
you just have to compute just a few bits
yeah so the the the the name of the game
is okay can you propagate these updates
in in this you know you know simplest
possible way the most effective possible
way right so we don't want to recompute
from scratch and this is where why the
incremental view maintenance problem
gained so much interest in particular
because databases are large it costs a
lot of time to recompute everything from
scratch so could we in fact just
recompute the little changes and apply
them then to the result
so that is the thing and this is why
also incremental view maintenance this
problem has a lower complexity overall
you know in general I would say well for
specific queries then actually uh just
really competing from scratch so we are
after this particular game
yes
so the question is what happens if you
know I give already a minus two but now
I want to do a minus four or a minus 2
again right so I'll get something
negative in here so there are several
interesting aspects to this
um I would say that uh you know well at
least in our four monies we allow that
yeah so you have a temporary state of
the database where multiplicity is may
be negative
what is the benefit the benefit is that
you can allow basically for updates to
come out of order and if you have a
batch of them you allow all of them to
be you know executed and only at the end
of the the execution you look at
basically the interpretation is that
whatever has a strictly positive uh you
know multiplicity is considered in the
database whatever doesn't have is not in
the database right but that allows me
for instance to do to to basically swap
between an insert and and a delete and I
can do delete first this is nice for
parallelization purposes you know for
various types of you know optimizations
it's also possible in the in the you
know if you have this distributed
setting right and then you you cannot
even want to enforce a particular order
of the execution because it precludes
the whole uh you know uh you know
parallelization you can achieve yes can
you do an update on a couple which is
currently not in the database yes
definitely and this is also a very
important aspect for instance if you
need in a in a matrix case you have n by
n you can only update something which is
in there right relations are more
General so you can insert something that
doesn't correspond to particular
coordinates I would say in a tensor or a
matrix right so I could easily insert a
3D one which will just be added here and
then I will check with the other tables
whether I have a join and I may add
something to the result
right so it's a fairly General thing yes
so and if you enjoy two negative
terminals you can positive
okay
how you do this well uh uh one one
aspect of how to do this is that when
you actually have to do the
multiplication
you have to actually account for that
right you know so if you multiply things
which are negative you get something
negative
result I think that this is the because
basically it means that they are out of
there and then that doesn't correspond
they're trying to count with it
yeah this stage whatever multiplication
you have you got to multiply
well let so let me take this offline
right so I can have a bit of time to
think about that yeah okay so but but it
is true that basically if you have
several negative ones
um uh the effect in the answer shouldn't
be you actually uh you know add the
positive effect right because this is
true
thank you very much
so let's actually look let us look at
the trundle count query so uh we have
this uh so so this is the way we'll
actually represent the the
query so uh we take this uh factors as
being these functions that the map uh
two plus a b right over the value say B
to some uh
uh uh you know uh element of a ring as
the same T the same and then we take a
sum over ABC
which means that basically by by this I
mean to say that I take a to iterate
over all the values in the active domain
which is you know the possible values I
have in this uh of a values I have in R
and T then B uh will be the same from
the active domain of B and C the same
and then for each Tuple ABC I check
whether RS and T are actually uh uh you
know satisfied and then I take their uh
uh um uh you know elements in the ring I
multiply them and that will contribute
to the overall sum so the problem is can
we maintain Q under single Tuple updates
to rsmt
okay
so there is a lot of literature on the
triangles
um so it served actually as a milestone
in many fields uh for instance for worst
case optimal joint algorithm so that was
one of the Workhorse uh showing that
actually we can get a lower complexity
than in the case of uh you know just
using standard query evaluation
techniques that join uh two relations at
a time uh then in parallel query
evaluation so that was basically you
know there is an article by uh uritzvik
but there is also by Hong and and
colleagues then apparent query
evaluation and the uh parties they
actually uh use the Triangular joint
query to actually show some some
interesting complexities in particular
lower bounds then we have uh also the
randomized approximation setting and
there are many other settings in streams
or static in the for asset in queries
under updates there is uh quite some
work done by uh Nicole schweikart uh and
uh there is a lot of system development
wants to which we also contributed and
we also have lower bounds in particular
by Virginia here
um and and this is thing these are
things we are going to use and also
basically the omv problem interesting
stock by uh Monica hensinger
so the question remains is there a fully
Dynamic algorithm that can maintain the
exact triangle count in worst case
optimal time
so there are several possibilities the
knife one is to recompete from scratch
so imagine we have the relations rsnt
and there is a sum
uh and we get a Delta to R we just
incorporate it in R and then we are left
with with the same query again which we
recompute so if n is the database size
then the update time would be could be
done in this N2 1.5 using a worst case
optimal drain algorithm uh but could be
slightly better using instruction like
matrix multiplication we already seen on
slides yesterday like into 1.41 if I'm
not mistaken and then uh the space
remains leaner because you just store
the input relations now there is
something which is actually the approach
implemented in uh virtually all
commercial database Management Systems
which is basically called Delta queries
so here uh you compute the delta and and
what is the idea the idea is that if you
get this uh Delta R to R right instead
of just appending it to R and then
recompeting from scratch we just compute
uh the join of Delta r with s and t
yeah so because the delta in our case is
a single Tuple update has specific Alpha
and beta values then uh it means that we
only look at the part part of s that has
a beta right for the First Column and uh
has Alpha for the second column in t
and then so we only need to uh to
basically sum up over C so this arguably
it is a simpler query as the original
query and uh in fact
we just need to take the C square with b
and the cspare with Alpha uh and then
intersect them right and that
intersection may actually take a linear
time in N because in general b beta in
Alpha may be paired with n possible uh
uh you know value C so uh after we do
this of course we just uh you know sum a
q with Delta q and get the new q and the
update time will be linear to intersect
the C values and then space remains
linear
um oh and I wanted to also mention that
this is called the first order
incremental sometimes because uh it is
actually
expressed at the level of the query
right the original query so you express
the the the the the computation of the
change just using another query so first
order query uh Ben uh this this was
introduced actually this idea of first
order uh in the to to contrast it to the
so-called higher order incremental view
maintenance which was proposed by
Christopher in his DB toaster system
where the idea is that you can take a
Delta of a query but that query may have
uh very many joints and you can actually
you know materialize some of these
joints
uh you create the then views and then
you can recursively maintain those views
so you get a recursive maintenance
scheme that maintains the first query by
using some materialized use and then
maintaining also this materials used
again with their deltas and this is why
it's called higher order
so in this case I want to show you for
this query that what I can do for
instance I can join SNP I can get a
materialized view that the sums over C
and then I only keep b and a yeah uh and
after that I have a simpler query uh
where uh for for which if I have a Delta
uh Alpha Beta I can do them just simply
uh on a lookup in the in the view and uh
and that will be cheap and then for this
reason I can actually uh uh compute this
particular update in constant time
assuming that the view is already
materialized uh but of course the caveat
here is that we also have to maintain
the view so the complexity is still
there right we still have some linear
complexity in maintaining the view and
and this is how it happens so if we have
let's say the view where we join SNT on
C and then we aggregate the way c
um then if we do a Delta to s right then
this beta gamma which is basically the
tupeline s in Delta s we then look up in
here and for a gamma we may have very
many A's we have linearly many A's uh
and uh so the the complexity for that
remains actually linear to do this yep
those are in fact uh Christoph
basically maintained all all the all the
all the pairwise joints right maintains
uh the actual view for St for RS and for
uh RT
to get the updates
good so um
but the space here however is the
problem because we have to pay for the
price of of materializing this view
right with the hope of you know speeding
up at least inserts to R so now knowing
that for instance R may be the only
updatable relation this really pays off
because you materialize The View once
you don't need to maintain it and then
the lookups to uh into the view will be
cheap from all the updates you do to R
yes
approach if you have to materialize all
these extra views how do you gain
anything I mean so okay for this
particular query you will not gain
anything you're right yeah but if you
want to materialize XT you will gain
sure yeah
and I yeah but how are you going Beyond
Frederick maintenance here what is is
this so the idea is that you get this
view materialized yet right so the query
becomes simpler and then you have to
materialize the view of the materialize
The View as well so you have to but the
viewers had the first or the definition
of it yeah no it's also materialized so
it's also stored on disk oh I see so it
is it materialization of it yeah exactly
exactly
which may actually speed up sometimes
yeah
okay so these are actually some
techniques which are uh quite common I
would say in the IBM right for for
databases now let me actually show a
different pool in the toolbox which we
may use which is basically how to show
lower bounds for maintaining the
triangle count
so for that I will look actually at the
at a simpler version of the query which
is the Boolean triangle detection
problem so effectively I have the query
but now I'm interested on only in
whether there is at least one answer
right and not counting the answers and
um
uh basically for for for this particular
uh triangle detection query uh problem
uh we can we can come up with the
following statement that uh for any uh
strictly positive gamma there is no
algorithm that incrementally maintains
the query with this update time right
and this enumeration delay
so what does it mean it means that here
we have n the size of the database uh at
the time uh we do the update and then
it's to the power of one over two minus
this gamma yeah in particular uh the
question remains whether we can we can
have an algorithm that can achieve it in
of n to one over two
right because going below is not
possible and then the enumeration delays
just in this case uh uh it says that it
can be can be linear
operation
it means answer time yeah so you want to
get the the answer
is
let's say simultaneously or individually
no it is applied together it's not
possible to get this and that yeah yeah
uh and we will see later that this
actually leads to some uh uh weak
optimality for some of our results in
the sense that we can have an algorithm
that matches both but uh it is still
possible that you know you keep one
that's presented here and the other one
can be decreased
right so that Still Remains silver but
we will get there so now is there a typo
here because you uh I was expecting one
to grow the other to shrink as uh
but here if you if I choose gamma to be
very
um uh very large it means I cannot have
no if I choose the number to be very
small it means I can't have
uh and
yeah so are you sure it's minus minus
here well I surely hope so because I'm
going to show the derivations of the
proof so uh yeah but uh but yes yeah
um but then they say lower bound so
basically you can't draw in both cases
you can't drop under half another one
yeah
so but for that I'm going to use a
rather uh more involved conjecture
so if I say lower bound and I want to
choose gamma as large as possible so I
uh as small as possible I want to choose
gamma to be zero
well I mean gamma has to be strictly
greater than zero and what it says is
that you cannot go below both of them at
the same time
right but if I choose drama very very
small that's kind of the best Indian
pins into the one half and end and that
is the strongest lower bound
so this this says you cannot do this I
mean it's very similar to these
statements that say for every Epsilon
you cannot get into the three minus
Epsilon times
okay
so let's see this so first of all let me
Define this only problem
so
um input would be an N by n Boolean
Matrix M and we are given n pairs of
vectors U1 D1 u n d m right uh and they
these vectors also have a size n
and what we want to do is the following
we want that after seeing every pair we
want to Output this uh this computation
which is the u r transpose M times V
right and that would be a scalar right
so now the idea here to make it Dynamic
that's also Regina explained yesterday
is essentially to force you to Output
after seeing every pair of vectors
all right so it doesn't allow you to you
know see more columns at the time more
vectors at the time and then you may do
some stress on like uh
right so uh and this is what we are
going to do so effectively we want to be
able to show that uh solving this
problem we can solve this problem using
our query
okay so the OMG conjecture uh status by
by uh uh Monica hensinger is uh the
following and others yeah for any gamma
greater than zero there is no algorithm
that solves other than D in time of n to
the three minus gamma so effectively you
cannot get it in sub cubic time
yeah the overall right so yesterday uh
we've seen it uh uh you know a similar
problem expressed where n was to the
power of 2 but that was meant amortized
per Vector pair essentially uh so now
there is the other conjecture which uh
our conjecture is implied by that our
conjecture so we can reduce this OMG
conjecture to our conjecture uh which is
also presented in the same paper and is
this the uh online Matrix Vector
multiplication problem and there the
idea is that we have again an N by n
Boolean Matrix M and we have these
column vectors V1 to v n that arrive one
after the other and the goal is after
seeing each Vector VR we want to Output
the multiplication of M with VR
yeah and this one here is actually also
the conjecture here is that there is no
algorithm that solves it in sub cubic
time
okay so a lot of the the proofs actually
also in the original stock paper were
done using the OEM V conjecture uh I
mean you know they were conditional on
that but then uh later on uh you know
this one uh was also shown to be a valid
one because it's actually also simpler
you don't have the pairs for us it's a
the Tactical is easier to actually work
with the oemd1
so what is the proof idea well the proof
ID is this assume there is an algorithm
a that can maintain triangle detection
query with amortized update time and
this enumeration delay
okay for some gamma now we want to
design an algorithm B that uses the
Oracle a to solve for you and v in sub
cubing time in n and if we manage to do
this then we contradict the O and the
conjecture
okay so what is this algorithm B first
of all we have to construct yeah given
our onv instance a database instance so
what do we do basically we take the
Matrix M and we just simply store it in
the relation s right so effectively as a
indices i j will uh will just have the
value which is given in The Matrix M so
it will be zero or one and in each round
okay of the algorithm we do this we have
relation R encoding the vector u r yeah
so again we just store the vector in
there but because relation R was a
binary relation on the First Column we
just put the constant a
so effectively we we make the query
simpler right instead of actually having
the join also on the First Column of r
with the last column of T there we put
just the constant a so it joins
trivially so we don't want to actually
influence uh what happens on the other
two columns on B and C
and the similarly in relation T we
encode the vector VR so as I mentioned
on the on the second column of T we just
put a the constant a yeah the same
constant as here
and then it will be easy to see by by
the construction that essentially the
result of multiplying this uh vectors
and matrices is exactly QB
yeah and then we have to check whether
QB is one using algorithm a
if we check that it tells us essentially
whether
will basically solve the the our
original problem on matrices so let me
show you an encoding for you mmv
um imagine that U is this one I put it
transposed yeah I show it like a
horizontal
Vector here and it has only the second
position uh value one the rest is zero
then the Matrix has this once and the
rest are zero and the vector is this one
here
we have this vector v which is now a
column Vector right so effectively this
index here 2 tells me I have to look at
the second row and this uh index one
here tells me I have to look at the
first column
right and I find that indeed one one and
one they make up a one
yeah now in databases what happens is
this as I said in relation r i put a as
the constant for the value of variable a
and then for B
I put the actual index
for the one values so we have just a one
value here and the index is two and for
that I put the value of 1.
for uh for m i just encode essentially I
just list all the coordinates of the of
the values one in there right like two
and one three and one one and two one
and three and three and three they are
all here with value of one as you can
see I don't need to store actually the
zeros right so this is a rather more
compact encoding of the Matrix which is
typical in databases you don't put the
values with the with the zero uh is is
what uh uh Val explained that that we
don't need to store explicitly those
that have an element of zero
and for tea I do similarly I have index
1 with the value one so it's one and
eight so now if you do the join what
happens is that you have to take this
two which is the the row index you look
here whether you have the row index also
two and then you look at the column
index one and see whether you have it
here and it is the case so then you
multiply one and one and one and you get
the one
yeah so that's essentially the the
construction so now let's actually look
at the algorithm B what it does so first
of all I said that I have to take Matrix
M and populate the relation s that takes
at most N squared insertions
uh then in each round I have to delete
all tuples in RNA T to prepare it or I
could construct a new database with a
new schema let's say a relation r with
index small R and T with index mode R so
I do at most to n deletions so these
deletions do not really affect us in any
way for the for the argument and then we
insert into rnt
which takes about two n insertions at
most yeah we just instruct as I
explained uh then we check whether QB is
one uh so the holds if and only if our
Vector Matrix Vector multiplication is
one and and this means essentially you
know if I detail that there is an i and
J such that I in u r is one that the
position mij is one and uh V at position
J is one
so then be constructs the database of
this size and the big n the size of
databases of N squared
small N squared yeah
good so let's actually see the time
analysis so recall that a needs this
amount of uh update time where you see
this I replace the big n by N squared
yeah and also I replace it here the big
n by N squared yeah for the delay so how
much you to take here well we have this
amount of updates in worst case because
we have this amount of entries in m and
for each of them it takes this update
time
so that gives us something of this form
n to the power of 3 minus 2 gamma now
let's see in each round what happens we
have four n updates because you know in
each of the two relations rnt we delete
first and then we insert and for each of
them we have to do this update time and
this gives us something like o of N
squared minus two gamma where gamma is
strictly a positive right so this means
this is sub cubic this is a sub
quadratic and then checking this
effectively means the answer time we
have to look at the delay
and the delay will be exactly this one
here because we have just a single value
when we just want to access it and that
gives me also some quadratic uh time so
now this is for one round if we actually
take these two quantities and we
multiply by n for all n rounds we get
something which is also sub cubic here
so what is the effect the effect is that
the overall time will be something sub
cubic which will contradict the oemd
conjecture
so this means that if we can solve our
query
faster than with the update time and the
delay I mentioned before this means that
we can also solve the oemp problem
faster than it is conjecture good so
this is another tool we actually use
right in IVM which is very much largely
borrowed from the algorithms community
um okay so now the question is can we
close the complexity Gap I showed you
some upper bounds which are done using
standard approaches and I showed you a
lower bound yes I just wanted to note
that the this reduction here is very
similar to a reduction that occurs in
Virginia in my paper from Fox 2010
yes in fact we show with arbitrary
polynomial time pre-processing you you
still can't answer the the queries uh
sub quadratic time so this is yeah this
is excellent so this is actually I I for
that I was mostly inspired by the
schwicax paper from 2017 in ports but
you know I I imagine there must be
somewhere done before already
Yes okay not the entire thing you said
no yes yes no but I I'll reach out to
them
I also I want to say one more thing in
the when Nicole gave her talk about of
the equivalence of all pictures past the
triangle same reduction works for an
equivalence of Boolean matrix
multiplication and regular triangular
detection and this ummd problem is the
dynamic version of triangle detection
whereas the OMD problem is the dynamic
version of Boolean matrix multiplication
so you've essentially seen the
equivalence of these two problems you
just have to make a dynamic
thank you so much for for the extra
applications so now let's see whether we
can close the complexity Gap so we know
we have this known upper bound yeah we
have some some known lower bounds now
yeah
um and um uh can we maintain the
triangle count with sublinear update
time is the question and the answer is
yes we can maintain it with this
amortized update time
um and and this would be worse case
optimal so let's see actually how we can
achieve that in fact I will show you a
very simple argument by which we can get
this amortized update time for some
parameter Epsilon that can vary between
zero and one right so uh and then uh we
get the space which also can vary from a
linear to uh
uh in this case 2 to 1.5
not to end to 1.5 and then we may have
also some pre-processing time that is
you know the time it takes initially to
to process if we start with an empty
database of course this would be a zero
uh pre-processing time and yeah some
time remains of one because this is a
scalar query but there are also other
queries which are non-scalar for which
of course we also would like to
understand the delay uh trade-off in
here which I will show you a bit later
so basically the picture looks like this
so let's see very Epsilon we can
actually get this space increasing and
then decreasing and the update time
decreases and then increases and then it
reaches an optimality for Epsilon is 0.5
for which uh amortize update time
becomes essentially square root of M now
for the argument of this lecture I will
I will just use the the simple uh uh a
rather simple approach for which indeed
blood space can increase but we have
another a slightly more involved
argument that keeps the the space leaner
which then matches also what what what
is actually known in the literature that
you don't need to increase the space
so let's look inside so there are
several techniques we use in order to
solve the problem like this one is that
we still need to compute Delta queries
the same way I showed you before we
still have to materialize views like in
the higher order IVM but there is a new
ingredient which is basically adaptive
processing Based on data skew
so we have to treat the heavy values
different from light values in order to
achieve that
um so effectively before you've seen
this as uh there are specialized
algorithm for for the sparse domain and
for the for the you know dense domain
now now we have to somehow put them
under the same roof in a way yeah so
let's see how this proceeds so we take
relation R right out of the three
relations and um we want to decompose it
into two into a live part in a heavy
part the light part uh should have uh
essentially the values a that are paired
with that most N2 Epsilon values of B
and and then we say that a is light but
in case we have an a prime whose number
of B's is actually greater than N2
Epsilon then that that would be
considered heavy
yeah so we split the relation R like
this into a light and a heavy part and
uh and uh one interesting thing we can
derive is that not only that of course
uh a is the the light A's will appear in
the most ends we've seen on uh tuples
but the fact that we can have at most H1
minus Epsilon uh heavy guys because if
each heavy guy you know has at least N2
Epsilon tuples and there are n tuples
overall you cannot get more than n21
minus Epsilon heavy guys
so these two upper bounds are actually
important in our analysis of the
algorithm afterwards so likewise we
partition s and t right uh partition on
one of their variables so we have then R
partition on a is partition on B and T
partition on C
um good so now Q our original query will
be the sum of all these queries right so
we have the the light part of r with the
light part of this with the large part
of T sum up with all other combinations
now the heavy with the light light and
so on and so forth so we have two times
two times two eight combinations and
then we'll have to look up and
understand how they actually uh behave
um so
let's consider we have an update to R
and I put here a star to say that uh you
know I don't care whether it's light or
heavy depending on Alpha I just you know
I can look up and find out okay let's
say it is in the light part but it's in
the heavy part and I will show you how
basically each of these four cases can
be considered under such an update so
that we can get the complexity I
promised you from the very beginning now
what is crucial is that uh to to
maintain to evaluate this Delta queries
actually for each of these four cases
yeah we have to use perhaps different
strategies we cannot use the very same
strategy the same you know in database
parlance the same query plan right
because if we use the same query plan
then then of course we do need to do the
partitioning in the first place yeah so
we have to be uh sensitive to the to the
heavy light partition
so these are the the Deltas now right we
have we want to compute the Delta of
this first query that is light on B and
light on C and then we have this uh
single Tuple update and we are now in s
and t we have uh uh you know just we
look at that part where the the B value
is beta and here the a value is Alpha
yeah and so on and so forth for the
others and let's see I think it is
actually didactically interesting to see
how this behaves so if we look at the
light light part yeah so we are in this
setting right we have Alpha and beta our
Tuple from Delta R and now we have in SL
just this part in TL only this part
what happens is this that we know B is
actually light in s right so it can be
paired with at most N2 Epsilon C values
uh for T we don't know much because uh C
is actually light but we don't know for
this a how many C's we may have however
what we know is that we have to
intersect this N2 Epsilon at most
C values with some C values and we can
take the minimum of the of the two sets
to give us the time to do the
intersection it is as if we enumerate we
we iterate over the season then do
lookups into this fragment to find out
whether we have a matching uh effect
so the update time will remains then N2
Epsilon yeah to intersect this list
and the and the and that's it right so
this is actually done so that's already
good because if Epsilon is actually uh
you know below one then we have a
sublinger uh uh update time now if we
look at the heavy heavy case right
um so what what means it means that here
uh the beta will be heavy but this
doesn't tell us much about how many C's
uh uh well it tells us that we have you
know many C's right more than N2 Epsilon
but what happens here is that uh T being
heavy on c
um
tells us that we can have but most n21
minus Epsilon C's
right so this is the thing so the so
this is the constraint we use at the
moment
so then the update time becomes uh all
V1 minus Epsilon why because you have to
intersect at most n21 minus Epsilon c's
with this season here and take the
minimum of the two
good so now let's look at the light and
heavy combination so we have a light on
beta so the number of C's here is
Epsilon and we also know that the number
of C's here is actually upper bounded by
n21 minus EPS you know so we know this
we know that we take the minimum of the
two so we get this
writing this particular case for the
update
so um but there is an interesting case
which actually you know can be set apart
from the other three uh mainly that uh
so where we are heavy on on S and light
on t
now what does it mean
um well one second it means that
basically we cannot really use uh well
we we know that beta is one of the heavy
guys
right so it exceeds the end to Epsilon
so we cannot use this as an upper bound
and here uh you know we don't have
anything on Alpha to Upper bound the
number of C's we have so we are a bit
stuck at the moment right so what we
could do at the moment is this we can
create a view
which materializes this joint of smt
yeah so we materialize the project away
C and we keep this one and once we have
this view of course it's very easy to
just do a lookup in the view right to
check whether beta Alpha are present
here and then get their payloads
um so the update time
would be all of one in this case but of
course what I did I shifted the problem
to the view in a way right so uh we
could do that and I will show you how we
can do the views but so far what we got
this is the picture right so we have uh
in case of light and light this is the
update time in case of heavy and heavy
this is the update time then uh for uh
uh light and heavy there are in fact two
possibilities we can use so we get this
the minimum of the two and then for the
last one we have all of one so overall
we get this update time
which is the the the the basically the
maximum of this you see here
yeah now let me go back to the view so
these are the auxiliary views we have to
maintain so we have to maintain for RNs
in case this is heavy this is light
again heavy light heavy light so this
combination that actually created
problem for us
so how can we do that so imagine we have
this View
and we want to have updates to uh s yeah
so we insert beta gamma into s
so then with gamma we then do a lookup
to find the ace now gamma being light in
P gives us an upper bound on the number
of A's paired with gamma so that's
actually good it gives us essentially N2
Epsilon upper bound now uh and and
that's that that's the time for update
to to S if we want to update to T
instead yeah we've gamma uh an alpha
then uh uh in s what we can see is that
um
the number of B's here would be upper
bounded by n two one minus Epsilon
because the B's are heavy
so again we can maintain this view in a
in in a good time in N to one minus
Epsilon and overall the maintenance time
for the views would be of this form
right this is the maintenance complexity
and the space is given by this because
we have to basically keep these views
around and these use cost us some some
extra space
okay
so okay so this is basically the
maintenance strategy yes
which is um
you can always look up and find out
whether you know for an alphabet I mean
certain you know for instance whether R
belongs to the heavy guys or to the like
guys for instance one possibility is
that you just do a lookup in like r or
and then heavier
okay so so far it looks good however
there is one particular caveat namely
that we depend so much on this light
heavy partitioning so what happens if we
start inserting a lot or deleting a lot
and our initial assumptions about heavy
and light are not anymore correct
right this is one thing another thing
that may happen is that we start
inserting so much or deleting so much
that all our thresholds which are based
on some parameter and size of the
database at some time becomes deprecated
right
we have to adjust for the new end for
the new size of the database so this
requires actually some some rebalancing
so effectively uh to do this
we have actually to to account for for
some amortization right so we have to
pay some price uh you know accounting
for the fact that every now and then
these two situations may actually happen
so one situation is depicted here we are
in our light a was light but then we did
so many insertions that suddenly a
becomes heavy
right so uh in that case we'll have to
transfer N2 Epsilon tuples from one part
to the other part right so uh when as
soon as it gets you know asymptotically
over the threshold of an Epsilon we have
to uh put it on the other side and this
time actually becomes uh the time of uh
inserting all these N2 Epsilon tuples
for for that light value previously like
value into the the heavy part so uh the
the time is a Max of Epsilon to one
minus 18 or to do one update and then we
have to do this N2 Epsilon times
yeah
so uh the other one is when we change
the heavy light threshold so we change
the size of the database so uh the
threshold was here but now the threshold
goes up
yeah and then whatever was considered
heavy for instance now becomes light
so in this case what we have to do we
have to recompute partitions and views
from scratch
and the time complexity will be this
right because this is basically the
space we took so all the views all the
tuples we have in there are proportional
to this yeah but what actually happens
is that even though both forms of
rebalancing requires super super linear
time uh we don't have to do them eagerly
every you know after every update right
so it is perfectly fine to uh wait for a
number of updates let's say proportional
to N2 Epsilon
before we actually do a minor
rebalancing and similarly we can wait
for something proportional to end right
size of the database number of updates
before we do a major rebalancing so in a
way think of it as you know you have you
invest at the time you do an update to
invest extra tokens right you know for
your insurance that you know every now
and then you may actually have to do
this sort of a major uh or binary
balancing right but the number of tokens
you have to invest with every update
will remain constant
but so the overall amortized balancing
time becomes this
good so there were there was actually
follow-up work uh in uh toads where we
look at triangle queries with different
free variables so here I showed you only
the case where you computed the scalar
but what happens if you want to output
for instance you know the edges
right or you know the triples that
represent the triangles
um and then we actually analyze various
Notions of optimality for these queries
there is actually from the algorithms
community and extension of this
algorithm to cake recounting and uh to a
parallel batch Dynamic triangle count
algorithm based on our algorithm and um
uh then in 2021 there was also by uh by
uh I think ufe Tower an extension to
look at the optic time and approximation
quality trade-offs for triangle Counting
where basically they look at the
complexity of the triangle counting
based on some notion some property of
the graph called arboricity
uh but open questions we have here would
be this yeah
um we don't really understand much about
the the lower bounds in particular for
uh General queries functional aggregate
queries and I will come back to this uh
in in the second half of the lecture and
uh what we realize also is that uh the
lower bounds
give us in worst case a rather uh high I
would say a lower bound four four four
four four single Tuple updates which
makes actually batch updates uh at least
asymptotically faster than doing single
Tuple updates for instance if you look
at the queries for those of you familiar
with the Lumi sweetney uh class of
queries where the triangle is just one
of them right uh if you look at Lumi
Suite E4 for instance statically you get
a complexity of n to four over three but
this lower bound is applicable there as
well so you can get a lower amount of
you know for a single Tuple update of
square root of n so n two one over two
but then if you then insert n tuples you
get the overall complexity of doing n
inserts to the database into three over
two which is obviously higher than the
N2 4 over 3 which is actually if you do
it statically
so there are several issues related to
this of course one is to better
understand this Gap in complexity
between doing single Tuple updates and
batch Updates this is one thing another
thing is perhaps that the notion of this
worst case uh you know analysis you know
for single Tuple updates is not the
right one and perhaps you know and
especially in practice we are actually
most likely going for average complexity
right so on average it may be that you
know uh uh you get for the Lumi sweet
thing I mentioned a complex of Entry one
over three Which is less than than what
actually you see here but the idea is
that you know some updates May cost more
some updates May cost less but on
average they cost 10 to 1 over 3.
and there are actually some references I
put here if you want the slides so uh to
follow up and with this I'm actually
done for the first part of the lecture
and I take a question yes thank you Dan
let's thank
[Applause]
yes we have time for questions
so that was one like so uh I was a bit
confused about your last point because
you talked about Beyond worst case but
you're you're using an amortized notion
right so you're already doing kind of an
average case analysis
well I mean it's it's a it's a
um so so the lower bound I showed you
right is with the Big O notation right
that you cannot get off of n to one over
two minus gamma
right so this means that uh uh you
cannot get below that but you know I can
have if I actually you know do a lot of
inserts let's say to the database I may
have server inserts that cost constant
time yes right but some of them of
course I don't know you know above n to
one over two right right okay so that
notion of the complex is different from
the from the one you perhaps have in
mind ah see so you want to average your
amortized time something yeah to
amortize basically all the overall into
average overall being searched
right so I get this sort of average
complexity
so it's a bit the different notion yeah
right do you really need to amortize I
mean actually thinking as you were
describing so you're you're worried when
n increases but uh I could uh simply
store the updates in a separate database
uh also of size up to n yeah uh and the
answer answer query twice once when the
static database runs on this growing
database when that one reaches
um but I'm not sure maybe you maybe
you're update them on the side may you
do a little bit of work on a third
database and by the time you reach and
you have updated you're right that in
practice I will never be a sea girl as
I'm here in theory
balancing uh and in fact it hurts a lot
so we try to actually implement this to
make it practical and so far the duties
out I mean uh simply because if you do a
simple Delta Delta it's a very simple
query right the logic is acceptable so
even though you know you know in for the
heavy guys it may not do the best
amortize over all the line guys for
which it does very fast right it will
overall gain you know uh you know much
better it will be much much faster than
let's say every now and then checking
the uh whether oh this is heavy this is
light even the simple if then else
checking whether should I do it in the
likes or should I do it in the heavy
case it's actually a problem I would say
in practice
so I wouldn't do it but it is true you
actually have some you take a snapshot
and you realize okay based on the
snapshot I have here this are like these
are heavy I work with them and very
rarely you actually look at uh you know
whenever you don't have a huge workload
you actually try to truly balance yes
a related question so you describe the
algorithm as a if you give an amortized
balance
building in the background definitely
the worst case yes yes so we have a
schedule the same thing so we have a
sketch of that basically the the
amortizing uh the algorithm essentially
yeah and we can do this
again theoretically yes this is possible
and definitely uh uh we can do that in
practice however you don't want to spend
that time you know because you have to
do extra work
or the eventual situation that you might
get there you know to to pay the price I
should mention for people who don't know
this but unlike many theoreticians that
actually goes and implements this stuff
and he's expecting his algorithms to run
better than state of the art which is uh
the competitive and historic
um so you are not using provenance at
all uh so you I mean
problems can be used for deletion uh
tracking right
you wouldn't uh gain anything if you
were to do that
to just remember
every Tuple how it was computed and just
to be honest we didn't really uh
especially I mean we're looking to this
actively I can see perhaps some benefits
in some cases you may do things faster
um in particular if you are not
interested in let's say precise counts
you are interested on in the existence
right I mean the province can already
tell you there is another derivation of
that result and then you can start
quickly
right uh but um but but we have to take
into consideration the maintenance of
the provenance itself which actually
cost the time so here uh that that was
an issue we didn't the reason why we
didn't consider it
yes please
um so it seems that this is completely
independent from the especially for
answering the initial program so it's
not always the case
uh no just um because this is all to
compute the Delta Q right like the Delta
to your query so
um is this always independent from your
initial query answering so whatever
strategy you might use to ask I mean
also for these data queries if I go to
the question right the question was
would the Delta approach be dependent of
the of the queries I mean you know there
is this meta idea that you know you
apply your Delta and then you solve the
query where One Direction is replaced by
a Delta relation so that is the same
right this is a general concept but of
course it depends how you actually
execute the Delta query on the actual
query you have all right and the and the
sizes the cardinalities and other right
I mean
but depending on the query itself uh the
strategy or Computing the quote right so
we saw some of these strategies for
computing queries on
that yes yes
you cannot really exploit to match
structure but for instance if you have a
simple inquiry software is simply
queries then there yes you have a lot of
structure that you can exploit in order
to lower the complexity of doing the
Delta right and I will show you towards
the end of the presentation the second
lecture that basically you can get the
notion of dynamic with which depends on
fractional height of the width right to
basically Express the the complexity of
uh
yes so the strategy of explaining the
relations into heavy and light
components how does that extend if you
have multiple queries that you need to
worry about saying
something else
um
the answer is Magic yes no the answer is
this I mean you know so far what we
looked I mean we looked at the class of
queries and we realized you know by hand
you know which uh partitioning
strategies would work would give us
something because no partitioning
strategies can actually give you
anything meaningful right I like you
know improving the complexity so that
was actually an open in paperwork
you know so there is no automatic
approach we really can be right for uh
uh you know except that you know you do
it for a couple of queries in a class
you realize that it's my work and then
you try to prove that it works for all
those places
and it lowers the complexity
yeah I'm just I'm just in general
wondering and just you know
it is subdivision into light and heavy
should be adjusted based on like a lot
of workflow of wearing that Mom this is
what you mean uh yes it could be uh we
look here in the individual at each
query and try to say something about the
query if you have several queries you
want to evaluate together then yes that
would be a multi-query optimization
problem and I think that yes it will
make sense that you know you go for a
particular strategy which overall gives
you best for the queries instead of
giving you best individually for each
query yes you are okay I proposed to
stop here take a coffee break and please
feel free to talk to them
[Applause]